una ceremonia elegante donde primó la
emotividad sobre la espectacularidad y
que nos dejó momentos para la historia
por una parte de sus anillos olímpicos
en madera que vienen de árboles que
fueron sembrados por atletas que
participaron en los juegos olímpicos de
1964 uniendo el pasado con el presente
las diferentes delegaciones que
desfilaron al ritmo de la música de
videojuegos algo que traspasa las
fronteras pero también que une a varias
generaciones además de esto ese
increíble momento de sus 1800 drones que
iluminaron el cielo de tokio formando un
globo terráqueo que flota sobre ese
estadio olímpico y gran momento de
creatividad japonesa mostrando cada uno
de los deportes los pictogramas de cada
uno de los deportes fueron tres hombres
y ellos los encargados de con su cuerpo
formar cada una de estas figuras y claro
el momento más esperado es por supuesto
cuando se encendió la antorcha olímpica
fue la omi osaka la tenista japonesa una
gran estrella aquí pero también en el
mundo la encargada de tener este honor
ella ascendió a lo que parecía un muy
estilizado monte fuji y allí en todo
alto estaba el pebetero que se abrió
como una especie de flor en cristal
momento muy emotivo y bueno así de
manera muy poética quedaron abiertos los
juegos de tokio 2020